hi everyone uh very good morning uh very
warm welcome to uh today's session or
today's webinar on data visualization
for sales and
marketing
with tableau
now
marketers uh basically understand that
when providing insightful analytics to
our clients
or reporting to the executives or other
business units
it's going to be important to know um
how you're going to unlock the value of
your data all right so be it across
sales or across let's say your email
campaigns your social media
or online sites uh like your your firms
all of these are dealing with hundreds
and thousands of interactions every day
so
uh as i was mentioning now uh you know
you across the uh sales or the the
social media the online site uh that
firms deal with there are there are
hundreds and thousands of interaction
that happens every day all right so uh
here's the big question how can the
marketers or sales team help your
colleagues uh you know in order to serve
the customers better with a data rich
insights that don't require
hours of effort or specialist knowledge
now that's the big question that's
exactly why we're here all right so
before that before we go on on
discussing this entire topic in detail
here let me introduce myself to all of
you all and also set across certain
ground rules so
there you go that's uh for hana emma
that's my name and a little bit about
myself that i'm gonna quickly let you
know about i'm in a credit tableau
desktop trainer and i've conducted 30
plus training sessions on tableau
desktop exam preparations
for close to about 300 plus participants
from multiple corporates and educational
institutes
uh in terms of certifications i'm an
accredited tableau trainer
for desktop i am a certified
microstrategy trainer as well as
microstrategy certified
in terms of my experience i hold a four
year plus years of total experience as
an id trainer and content developer
in terms of my role well i'm an
education specialist with about four
years of experience in bi application
with expertise in microstrategy and
tableau
in terms of training i'm an expert
tableau and microstrategy trainer with
four years of experience where i'm also
into designing courses content
development facilitating various
training programs so i've delivered
across various trainings on tableau and
microstrategy courses in india and
overseas as well uh and yes of course
i've posted many webinars on tableau as
a subject matter expert as well
so that's going to be all about me here
now so let's begin now uh before we
start discussing on
on on
how we're going to be uh talking about
some reasons of why making sense of data
is important all right uh what i'm going
to do is i'm going to quickly put up a
poll session here for you all all right
so i'm going to request each one of you
all just give me a few moments here and
let me just put up a poll question open
for each and every one here
and before that let me quickly check on
the questions if any
all right
um
in terms of what is data visualization
we're definitely going to talk about
that so um i hope you can just hold on
while i come on to that topic so yes i'm
going to explain what is data
visualization shortly as i proceed ahead
all right uh as mentioned please ensure
that you're going to put in all your
questions in the q a section while any
confirmations regarding uh whether you
can view my screen screen frozen voice
not heard heard all that in the chat
section while questions in the q a
section all right
so i'm gonna post up the poll give me
about a few seconds here and let me just
quickly post up the polio for you all
so uh
here's the question now it seems that uh
all right
i do not have the privileges to put up
the poll so let me quickly ask you all
the question out here let me put it up
on my notepad and probably each one of
you all can just look at the notepad and
answer on to the question i think that
should work fine as well uh use the chat
section in that case to reply to me so
yeah you can make use of the notepad as
well for that matter not a problem there
all right
so that's that was my poor question
so
how do you use the data to market the
sense of your interactions with the
customers uh option a we don't
option b we look at the broad pitcher
but we need to do more like in terms of
using twitter or email or additional
websites
um option c that is we pay an agency to
do it but we need to work more closely
to better understand the data
and option d that we use a visualization
software
so quickly pull in uh put in your
answers here in the q a section and
let's just quickly understand the kind
of analysis each one of you all perform
in terms of interacting uh with your
data with your customers or your users
all right so i have a few people there
there perfect thank you everyone for
putting in those answers that are
definitely helpful so we have
option d that is using visualization
software looking at a broad picture uh
we don't at this point of time by two
people are using visualization software
there again
sounds good i request each one of you
all to please
uh put in your answers to this
particular question into the q a section
option c and d that's absolutely great
you pay an agency to do it but you need
to work more closely and of course you
use a visualization software as well
uh we don't all right so that's what
we're here for
uh sounds good so we have a mix of uh
pattern urine that your that is getting
used by people please keep sending in
your answers uh so that we can we can
analyze it in a broader sense as well so
basically that's what i wanted to
understand that you know how do you use
the data and when you say we don't or
when you say we look at a broad picture
but we need to do more or when we say
vpn agency or using a visualization as
well for that matter now all these four
answers are somewhere are linked in
understanding in in knowing and
identifying that
we want to know that's that's the reason
that we want to understand that as
marketers as salespeople
how can we provide additional insightful
analysis all right so let me move back
to my presentation slide here and start
talking about it
now
we have 72 hours as you can see in terms
of youtube video and you must be
wondering what is all these statistics
all about so 72 hours of youtube video
571 new websites
about 100 million new emails and
277 thousands of tweets
all these you're going to be surprised
to know are created every minute as per
the statistics these are created every
minute now that's a really really large
number all right so as marketers um you
know we don't need to collect all that
information but then uh this data is
definitely gonna be helpful uh you're
gonna get to learn a lot from it and you
want to you wanted to use this
particular information in terms of when
you want to come up with certain ads and
campaigns or you want to come up with
with certain uh
you know schemes or offers or strategies
that you want to come across
now
not many of us
you know get a chance to take a look at
all this data or play with that data or
look at it across various channels
so
what happens is your your companies they
expect us to be joined up in terms of
thinking and understanding the various
channels of marketing so you have uh
different channels as you can see like
uh you you can tweet and you can send
emails you can use websites youtube
videos uh you can you can for that
matter other than just use a lot of bulk
smsing and calling
as well as different schemes depending
on the kind of marketing strategy or the
kind of marketing that you're performing
the kind of customer the kind of channel
that you're working for all right so uh
that is a kind of expectation so what
happened so let me let me talk about uh
there was a question raised as well that
when you have so much of data uh what is
the difference if you have just normal
data versus data visualization what's
the difference all right so
there you go
uh data versus uh visualization so as
you can see on my left hand side here
this is my data in a visualized in a
visual manner in a pictorial graphical
manner as you can see while on my right
hand side here you can see that it's
just plain set of data that is being
used all right so uh now that's a pretty
clear picture here as you see that uh
you know i don't think um any of us
would like to present or would be like
to be presented with a large amount of
table
right here on the right hand side or the
information then that we need to
interpret uh it it just doesn't work you
know that's the whole point of wanting
to use a visualization
and tableau is just the right one in
that case all right so what happens is
now uh there are various visualization
tools and uh you can use them you can
you can perform and you can in order to
analyze and use your data to interpret
easily
it's going to be uh you know easy in
terms of using these kind of
visualization tools where you can
convert your raw data as you can see
into a more graphical pictorial manner
it's more easy to identify than in that
case like on your left ear it's talking
about food products and based on the the
graphical view you're on the triangle
the the heights and size you can
actually identify that which particular
food category your is least sold or used
in terms of or has more sales in that
case or more category depending on the
kind of visualization right so uh that's
how you can actually you can see uh
clearly the databases visualization
challenge here all right so but
something that we do not consider now
now it it doesn't always work that way
that you know the the whole point of
using visualization uh is going to be
helpful because you do not want to keep
kind of using these kind of raw data raw
tables here and interpret what's coming
up so when you have something more
pictorial it it's more easy it's more
about making your large amount of data
approachable uh in fact you know what we
do is uh putting this this large data
into a form of a graphical
representation that allows us to
interpret the data more easily right so
um let me say that um this is an art
that is involved uh it's like an ad
involved when you're working with data
converting it into a visualization
because uh you can use various tools and
you can start creating this
visualization okay so uh now tableau
contains various visualizations that you
can use in order to analyze and use your
data that you want to interpret in an
easy manner you do not need to be an id
expert you do not need any kind of iit
support as such that comes in uh you do
not need to be an expert in that
particular tool uh it's that user
friendly it's it's that quick to pick up
and learn and start analyzing that it is
amazing and at this point of time uh
it's one of the leading tools for that
matter in terms of data and
visualization here all right so uh but
something that you have to be careful
about now as as marketers as sale team
people uh you need to be really really
careful about
how you're going to create and interpret
your data all right you need to think
about what you don't want to know and
what you want to know because uh because
then of course uh you know you cannot
get paralyzed with the information of
what you don't have all right so you
rather work with what you have and then
come on with the analysis
so
now when they talk of that where exactly
do you start so where do we get started
in that case so
the the number one rule is that don't
rush in all right don't get hung up with
all the data that you've got you've got
huge massive data and the the number one
rule that we've absorbed and notice is
that a lot of times marketers go in are
rushing in wanting to
uh you know just get there and start
analyzing creating those visualizations
and and you know there you just want to
have it all so rule number one and never
rush in don't get hung up with the data
that you have so um that's in fact the
the number one reason that um people
don't get started with interacting with
your data at first so ideally if you've
been working in a real life scenario
you've been working with uh creating
visualizations and tools you'll notice
that uh you do not just jump into
creating visualization so what happens
typically now uh typically uh let's say
i would start by looking at the various
points of
where i would want to start interacting
with my customers uh understand the
aspects of the points that i want to
alter
let's say i'll find out about the
process uh how is the particular process
being followed for that particular
customer or user that i'm working on
strategizing my marketing or sales
strategy
let me give you an example here in this
case um uh so let's let's consider our
website now i would want to see how many
different channels on uh my websites are
being accurate you know how many
different uh
channels across the market there or are
being marketed or using a website so i'm
gonna start gathering the details and
usually once that done once i start
analyzing with what i need uh people
would want to jump on to creating
dashboards but
that's just assumed you know because you
think you have all the data
and hence
you think that there you have a clear
picture and that we should start working
on it but in reality it's something like
this all right so it's it's pretty murky
you're not entirely sure of what you're
looking at uh so while you're thinking
that you have some insights you have
some data
uh the the actual picture is that you
don't
and uh when you start using this inside
it it really doesn't work and you have
to go back and it does not make sense so
how are you going to go about in coming
on to this particular situation where
it's picture perfect or straight road
ahead wide and clear that you can move
forward instead of being in this
particular reality a scenario that is
pretty murky or as you can see so what
are the steps that you need to worry
about before you get on to that
visualization
let's start talking about those so the
very first challenge now that's going to
be the quality of your data
all right so um
normally uh the the most boring part uh
honestly that's going to be the most
boring part of this journey that uh
you've got to understand how good the
quality of the data is and based on that
you need to then act accordingly so uh
what you're gonna do is you you have to
check and ensure uh you might wanna find
out if the data that you have is it
being entered manually by a particular
sales or marketing team uh is there an
automated way that's being used uh what
is the approach in that case uh that's
being used so uh based on that or that's
how you would want to come on to the
analysis there all right and uh start
understanding the the quality start
understanding how good the quality of
your data is and based on that you will
want to start working on it accordingly
all right so uh now once you've once
you've understood you've analyzed the
quality of the data are this can be
cleaned further it it is possible to use
the data such that
you can produce additional information
so you need to be really really careful
with that because
um this is a really long time consuming
process and it is very very very
important now if you notice i'm really
stressing on the barrier because this
process it makes a huge difference on
what you analyze and what you don't
analyze all right so uh before i move on
to discussing on the other steps that
you need to worry about before you
actually jump on to creating certain
visualizations i just want to confirm
does anyone have any questions there
uh what are the steps to take if data is
entered manually or automatically uh all
right uh join the uh in case if it's
taken in manually or automatically
that's what you need to identify because
uh in if it's done manually you need to
be more careful in terms of getting your
data cleansed because there can be uh
instances where there can be
possibilities of errors in that case a
lot of times that we've seen because if
i'm entering it manually i might miss
out on a particular entry or at times i
might just add in a particular error in
terms of putting in a particular
numerical data so that's what you would
again want to check and identify and
confirmed in case if it's done
automatically you need to check at what
level is it uh entered is it happening
at a monthly level a weekly level and
based on that trying to understand when
you're creating a visualization uh
whether uh you know you want to come up
with a monthly analysis or a yearly
analysis or quarterly analysis so based
on the automatic updates you might want
to uh you might want to then understand
that the data that you're going to
finally come across uh the cleanse data
that you're going to work on further
should it be then rolled up or rolled
down for that matter to achieve the
monthly or the quarterly or the yearly
levels that you want to analyze at
so
based on whether it's manual or
automatic you need to clean it further
and uh and and come up with a more
systematic or more cleanse uh more
transformed data that can be used a more
structured data that can be used
so i hope that answers your question
there joey
so talking about challenge now the the
next thing that you need to know is that
you need to understand your data as well
so the next challenge is in terms of
understanding your data so once you've
identified that whether it's a manual or
an automatic data as i mentioned uh just
a couple of minutes back based on
joyweed's question
uh now now usually uh we notice that we
aren't starting from the scratch
data needs to be collected from yours
and over time and definitions of that
data can keep getting altered so what
you need to understand about this data
is that how is it going to be collected
what is the situation in which it's
being collected so let's see let me give
you a perfect example here in that case
that uh we did an analysis of a
particular location and people
interacting with a specific campaign all
right and in this case in terms of
collecting the data we were using ip
data
now ip data is um your data that gets
produced wherever you go to websites via
our mobile or
computer and we're looking at other
locations so uh we found out
interestingly that a middle east company
were mostly located in north america now
that's a surprising factor isn't that
and this kind of an information it's a
quite huge info
but that's not something that you know
we were expecting and of course um this
is a very simple example that uh clearly
explains that where things can go wrong
so uh because of the situation a lot of
people in the middle east connect to
their internet uh that is they connect
via the vpn which connects to their
north american head office and uh that's
how they serve the net so while the ip
data uh it's it's a good day of
understanding the location a large
portion of the audience was connected
via vpn and what we were actually seeing
in terms of the location was your head
office and this can completely ruin the
interpretation of your results so as
marketers our sales team you also need
to be
one of the biggest challenges that with
the quality you also need to understand
uh as i mentioned whether it's manually
entered automatically entered where
exactly are you gathering this
particular data from so uh based on this
example that's how you realize
how important and critical it is
to understand how your data is being
collected all right now um talking about
outliers uh this kind of uh an example
again uh we we often remain uh focused
on the major reason of doing the
campaign uh the major chunk of people
that we want to reach out to so uh it's
the outliers that can help us identify
or that can also play or spoiler to a
whole campaign so with tableau you have
various visualizations that you can
start using in terms of identifying the
outliers so we have we have
visualizations like the sparkline we
have visualization like the scatter plot
those are what help us in identifying
the the outliers and makes it easy for
us to come on to our particular analysis
all right
so
uh with with these now now with the kind
of challenges with with these challenges
of understanding the quality of the data
understanding the
uh you know the the whole data that you
have there uh moreover you don't want to
rush into it now we can actually start
thinking about visualization so with all
these challenges we can now see that
it's a bit pretty good clear situation
to move ahead and you can actually start
thinking about creating your
visualizations because now you
understand your data you've got the data
cleaned and structured that you can
bring to use and based on that you can
now use your tool that's tableau to
start visualizing this data all right so
we can now start seeing our data and
looking into deeper insight in analysis
but before you do that what's important
is that you need to start questioning
and
analyzing and uh on based on what you
want to build so you have your data now
it's cleansed you need to now start
considering that the end user whether do
they understand the visualization uh you
may be creating the visualization but
you might not be the end user for it so
the trick here is to really understand
the audience or the goals and things
like that so uh you know because tableau
can allow you to get into deeper
analysis and go further with your data
where you can ask more questions on what
you already have
but at the end of it all uh your
visualization needs to be valuable
otherwise it's just going to be creating
a pretty picture but it's not going to
be significant enough so
that's what you need to understand in
terms of question a lot try and come up
with what exactly am i trying to present
so let's say i'm gonna be presenting uh
my data where uh i'm trying to analyze
uh let's say my sales across time now
when i want to portray something like
this one of the best examples would be
that i would want to use uh from the
various visualization that tableau
provides i would want to use a line
graph because that's that's one of the
best visualizations to be used so
you need to consider at the same time
that when you're using visualizations
which is the best one what is the usage
of each one of them so uh they can look
pretty pretty in terms of putting it up
but
which one is ideal in terms of the kind
of analysis you want to perform is what
you might want to look at so i've opened
up tableau urine let me open up the
sample workbook uh the superstore uh
workbook that's present here and quickly
give you a
outlook on this is what your tableau
those of you never worked on it at all
all right so uh basically i'll just run
you all through the slides that i was
using earlier a few minutes back just
give me a moment there and then i'll
switch back to the environment so
ideally i was talking about
uh we were talking about data versus
visualization where i was on this
particular slide and then we moved on to
talking about where do we start and as i
mentioned it's a clear picture that you
can see but in in an ideal reality
that's not the case it's a pretty mucky
talent you need to check on certain data
challenges like the quality uh
understanding your data identifying the
outliers and then finally you have a
cleansed data that you can make use of
and start thinking about a visualization
now once you're through you need to
start questioning of what is the kind of
visualization or analysis that you want
to provide and that's how i then moved
on to the
tableau environment here all right so
based on this uh so here we were we're
uh talking about there was a question
put up by joy deep in terms of how do we
cleanse the data uh joy that you have a
lot of etl as you as you call in terms
of etl that is your extract transform
and load you have these particular data
team that help you in cleansing your
data you have various tools as well that
can be used so you have you have
informatica or you have various other
tools uh that can help you in terms of
cleansing that particular data so
you can do it manually as well but then
yes that's definitely going to be time
consuming and you have certain data
cleansing tools as well to make use of
so i hope that answers your question
there joey so
based on
uh
the the tableau here that you can see
that uh this is a particular dashboard a
visualization as you can see where you
have the entire executive overview based
on a map visualization a map that's been
used here and notice now we have the
monthly sales by segment and product
category now when i hover over let's say
i'm on as you can see a tool tip here
and i can see details about the profit
ratio sales and profit for washington
now the moment i select
on washington notice that my data now is
providing me information specific to
washington it's got filtered out here
where i can see the sales by segment and
by product category specific to
washington state
similarly when i click anywhere around
the map now you can see it's changed and
giving me details for all the states
across here for different segments that
is my customer corporate and home office
and my different product categories like
furniture office supplies and technology
all right let me do that once again so
this time let's select on new york
and there we go data by segment and
product category at monthly level so
you're in the map first thing that i'm
doing is i'm able to identify based on
the size of the bubble here in my map
all right based on that i'm able to
identify the the bigger the size you're
in that case uh that's how i can
understand whether uh you know what's
what's the sales you're in that case and
in in terms of the color the profit
ratio so the more the color in terms of
a bluer range or the more higher is the
profit ratio while more in the amber red
color the profit ratio in that case for
that state is on a lower side so that's
how we can identify the bigger bubble
the more the sales the uh more bluish in
color for that bubble the more is the
profit ratio when i select on a
particular state in that case uh it's
giving me filter data here below for my
graphs all right then comes in the
product analysis where again i have a
simple highlighted table where when it's
highlighting it's giving me details
across different months for every year
for my product category all right and
here again the color is helping me
identify at the same time that uh you
can identify the the more darker the
blue uh the more the sale so the month
of september ideally some month of
september november and december has more
sales for that matter something about
this particular uh month where i can
have a high level of sales that keep
happening uh which is a pretty much
chain across the years
and here again when i click on let's say
my
december 2013 for furniture
it is now providing me a filtered data
it's highlighting as you can see just
the selection and providing me data just
for my furniture across various customer
segments so these are the different kind
of visualizations that you can start
creating using tableau your and or start
providing information but what you need
to consider your in this case now let me
just open up a new sheet here and you
can see that tableau provides these n
number of visualizations that you can
create form but it's not necessary that
each time you might want to use uh each
each one so there is a reason uh
depending on the kind of analysis that
you might want to then select and choose
so as i mentioned when you're trying to
analyze
particular data over time uh line graphs
are one of the best examples that you
can use
when you have let's say you have
additional analysis like here in this
case uh this is a bullet craft that's
being used because uh you just have if
you notice one particular uh sales
measure here and that is helping us
identify the target sales the difference
as well so just one measure but
depending because of the visualization
we can actually identify the ones which
are above and below target as well so
these are the different analysis that
you have to come up with you need to
start questioning you need to start
analyzing what is the kind of
visualization that you want to pick up
is it going to be friendly in terms of
the user that you're creating for
right so that's the kind of questions
you need to come across and based on
that
come across with
the kind of visualizations that you want
to select
right
so
let's understand
that when you question what are the
things that you need to consider before
you go on to picking on
the different visualizations all right
so one you need to be you need to be
aware of aggregate data
i'm going to give you a quick example
here where one of the universities all
right uh
this was uh statistically seen that it
was a male gender bias in terms of
graduate admissions where you can see
that we had about 8 000 plus applicants
which were males and out of which forty
four percent were admitted while just
four thousand and uh plus applicants
where we had only thirty five percent
that were admitted so um at a department
level now most of the department had a
small but statistically significant bias
in favor of women now why that happened
was in actual in reality if i would just
see an aggregated data i would feel that
it's a male gender bias this is uh one
of the informations if you want to know
more about this particular detail uh you
can get this information from this
particular uh site that i picked it up
from where the source is from science
pickle uh which was in 1975 so
uh the situation was that that was not
really the case because women were
applying for more competitive
departments which had low rates of
admission so while they were getting
into uh arts or any other kind of
competitive department
uh tend to apply to less competitive
departments are in in that phase in 1975
and hence it showed a more high rate of
admission so you need to be what i'm
trying to explain here is you need to be
aware of uh the aggregate data as well
you need to get in and understand the
crux of it you need to get into the data
and identify uh whether it is ideally
the scenario or is it just you know
don't go blind with the visualization
and the data
another important point is be aware of
the y-axis bias as well now if you see
the view here all right all your data
that you have from the month of march
until july
fall under the very basics starting from
a 3.142
now this can be millions or thousands uh
the unit can be different here but it's
ranging if you notice right from 3142
ranging up till the highest of being
five two
now in case if i zoom uh this is my zoom
detail because of which i can identify
that uh you know i kind of uh then feel
that my july is ideally making a high
amount of um
you know sales let's let's consider that
this is sales across every month now
because it's an extremely zoomed in
feature here that i can use uh i would
assume that if july is really
incremented and giving me better sales
but that's not the reality because if
you zoom out you can see that they're
almost all in the range of three
millions or three thousands or thirty
thousand or however these units are so
you need to be really aware of the
y-axis basis as well you need to put
that in considerations as well when
you're creating your visualizations
now you can also go beyond the bar chart
so instead of just using bar chart
tableau provides 26 plus visualizations
that you can create and various
additional ones as well that you can
create in terms of
certain work rounds so as you can see
here you can create a bubble chart as
well where this is a packed bubble where
based on the size based on the way uh
you will be able to analyze and identify
you can start using a pie chart a tree
map so let me switch on to the tableau
environment here and quickly uh create
one or two visualizations here for that
matter so a great thing about tableau is
uh let's say i'm gonna i want to analyze
the ship mode and what is the uh profit
that is
uh uh create what is the profit that is
made across the ship mode now when i've
selected these particular
dimensions and measures as you call it
in tableau which is the the contextual
and the numerical data
when i click on the show me option now
all the visualizations suitable for
using the kind of
selection you've made it kind of gets
highlighted you can start using and it's
suggesting in blue here that the kind of
best possible visualization in this case
is a horizontal bar uh the the
requirement as well the other ones that
are grayed out either does not fit into
the basic requirement for that
visualization or it's not best suited
all right so tableau automatically
identifies and helps you in picking up
and choosing the particular
visualization as well now
let's see let me choose
discounts as well
and instantly notice now from a bar it
is now suggesting it's highlighting that
since i'm using two measures two
numerical data it is more sensible that
i start using a scatter plot in terms of
identifying my view
let me click on it
and tableau has automatically identified
based on my four kinds of shift mode
with the different kind of shapes here
where i can actually start aggregating
and identifying the discounts and the
profits for each of the ship modes and
if you notice your standard class have
the highest amount of profits as well as
the highest amount of discounts as well
that have been provided all right so uh
in case you want to change this
particular visualization now this is
where we were talking about that you
need to start questioning and also
identifying that is this going to be
easier for your end user all right uh in
terms of identifying and interpreting
the data maybe not so although this is
one of the best kinds i might just want
to give them a simple bar graph in that
matter all right so here i can then
again start manipulating i can start
changing i can swap my axis here wherein
i can talk about profits and discounts
let's say i want to compare between them
so i would want to create a dual access
so
right here i can from the drop down
select a dual axis and i can now start
identifying the discounts and profits as
well all right on a similar access here
i can change the kind of
view that i have let's say i want to
create a combination it's picking up the
automatic graph type i want my discounts
to be a bar
and i want my profits to be aligned so
there you go it's that simple that's how
you can keep making use of tableau and
you can keep creating on different kind
of visualizations there all right so you
can actually go beyond the bar charts
and you can actually start creating each
one of them and uh
you will further ahead when you have uh
when you enroll for uh understanding
when you we have uh simply learn
providing you a detailed uh course on
tableau on how you can use it what are
the different visualizations uh that's
where you can start understanding them
in detail now in barnard i'm not really
going to be able to provide
complete details here so uh this is this
is more like a discussion of how it can
be useful so yes a tablet is going to
allow you to go beyond the bar charts
another important consideration another
important thing that you should keep in
mind is that do not go overlord with
your visualization because tableau
allows you to do so much don't go
overload where you're using multiple
maps you're using multiple graphs right
within the dashboard and it becomes
difficult in terms of analyzing the data
for your end user uh you can also see as
best practices the placements are not
really proper in that case so this is
one of the classic examples of a visual
overload as well as a
a poorly built dashboard so let me go
back to the tableau environment and you
can see that it kind of makes sense your
your entire analysis needs to make sense
in terms of when you're trying to
identify uh there needs to be a story
that you're working on that you need to
be uh it needs to have a connect or link
so let's say i'm going to go on to the
custom or dashboard here so if you see
one and first trying to analyze the the
count of customers the sales the
quantity the sales per customer the
profits and their ratio across different
regions now based on that when i select
let's say the sales for west region it
is automatically now filtering my data
right here where then i can identify my
sales and profit uh based on my customer
and right here then let's say i am going
to select that
i can see that raymond raymond here has
is providing me the highest amount of of
sales and profit here so right here i
can see and analyze the customer ranking
as well so there's a particular flow
there's a particular story that comes
into picture so you need to you need to
ensure that you're not overloading data
that there's logic between what you're
creating when you're wanting to
visualize use multiple filters as well
so let's say now i do not want to uh you
know i'm in terms of a particular
department taking care of just
technology i don't want to find out the
entire category here i should be able to
filter my data specific to just
technology so right now i have my data
specific to technology and i can see
that overall what's my customer ranking
what's my sales and profit overall for
the customers if i select on a
particular uh
region i want to find out who's my top
customer in in central so there i have
tamara i have tamara chan that's uh my
highest customer ranking in terms of the
sales that have been provided all right
the sales and profit by each of the
customers so that's how you need to
create and think on building the
visualizations
let's go ahead
and
with that uh let's let's talk about the
the key takeaways that your
visualization should inform not just uh
it should be more information based not
just a pretty look when you're wanting
to provide visualizations because as you
noticed tableau allows you to create a
lot of visualizations it's got 26 plus
uh options automatically that allows you
to create based on your selections of
the data that you have uh so so consider
that it should also make sense in terms
of analysis it should allow you to get
certain additional info a lot of
potential inside where you can start
with the most uh important information
first but uh mostly also don't forget in
terms of understanding and cleaning your
data get it cleansed first get it
structured so that it starts making more
sense and based on that look at outliers
where you want to probably identify or
have your potential new opportunities
that you want to find out
understand what you're trying to take
away from your data uh let that guide
you based on that the kind of choice of
visualization that you want to make shy
away from the the kind of dashboard
overlord that you create because you
might want to give all the information
at once which i really would not uh
should not be the right case and in most
cases we've seen that uh you know and
and uh customers come back saying that
i'm really not getting what this entire
visualization is all about it looks
pretty it looks picture perfect but uh
not really helpful so uh uh don't shy
away from from dashboard overload and
moreover don't forget that more often
than uh in marketing you're actually uh
you're dealing with data which involves
people so consider that as well and um
you know you know uh talk about that so
uh just to sort of wrap this up uh i'm
gonna say that uh you know tableau has
uh it allows you to use visualizations
that can help convert your data and help
gain more insight and drill in and play
with your data so as marketers you
really really have to be careful in how
you're going to be presenting it and
understanding the data and be
responsible about what you're doing all
right so uh that is something that you
have to consider
and
based on that
that's what simply learn helps you in
you know giving you more details so uh
we're your company your that provides
you various courses we have about
thousand ten thousand plus uh
professionals every month with 400 plus
courses and spread across 150 countries
so
that's where
we're the largest or certification
training destination as you can see so
have a good day everyone
you